hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
seeing how we are still in the month of
love I figure it's time to ask a
cinematic question about love that seems
to be plaguing a lot of people's minds
is Twilight the worst thing ever the
books the movies the all-around
phenomenon
nothing generates more brainless love or
cynical hate than Twilight but is it
really worthy of as much cinematic
disgust as it gets
of course it is it's the worst cinematic
Brennan don't you never have to what I'm
getting at is people seem to regard this
franchise about a drama addicted twit
torn between an emo tastic vampire and
an ice tray stomach werewolf as one of
the worst in entertainment history
both cinematic and literary and given
the lineup of bad movies we've gotten
over the years is Twilight for lack of a
better term deserving of that title well
let's get down to what people really
hate about it and this is what the
classic war most famously vampires don't
Sparkle people have made up their own
rules about vampires before but this one
seems to be the most not vampire there's
also plenty of plot holes and
established story elements that never
seem to truly add up even within the
silly additions they make to the
supernatural world book and while these
additions are phenomenally stupid I've
seen Garbage Pail Kids so what else you
got the effects are terrible
again Garbage Pail Kids next it's
nothing but female-oriented smut well
your clothes it sparked the authors of
female-oriented smut but these two don't
even hit the bed sheets until part 4
part 1 and to its credit I do think the
bed gave the best performance it did not
look happy to be a flat surface for flat
characters this was actually a suicide
not too many people know that but I
digress
the story is focused albeit poorly on
the emotions of the characters you know
when they actually decide to show
emotion well don't get me wrong it's
horrible at it but that doesn't make
it's mud until apart for and even then
the rewards of such an act or not
reward II so that leaves us with one
last major aspect that people seem to
hate the most the characters and their
complete fucked-up ethics the fact that
these people are some of the stupidest
and most selfish creations that any
financially successful series has ever
produced and yeah they are first you got
Edward who has been around for more than
a hundred years and yet still managed to
not grow a personality which figures
because he falls in love with another
personality stricken bland job but we'll
get to her in a bit they sure little to
no chemistry yet he constantly wants to
throw himself at her feet so much so
that even dollar store romance novels
are telling him to grow a pair he also
likes to break up with her yell at her
getting contrived cockfights calls a
literal miracle of birth and evil
abomination
but that's okay because women like a bad
bet Jacob is the other idiot who seems
to have the hots for Bella he seems to
be a little smarter than Edward and even
supportive of those he cares about but
he is still attracted to Bella which is
why I used the term little smarter than
Edward his big controversy outside being
allergic to shirts as he imprints on a
newborn baby which in Twilight land
means he has marked her to be his future
mate making him a deado wolf
I guess this part never bothered me too
much because nobody fully knows how
imprinting words because they just made
the shit up I always thought he was just
doing it to protect Bella's kids so the
other wolves wouldn't kill her or even
some made-up wolf bullshit sense could
see the future and see that they would
one day be a couple I don't know they
made it up and it doesn't make a whole
lot of sense so how am I supposed to get
angry with if I don't even understand it
that's it it is pretty weird to watch a
kid grow and I guess be thinking yeah
I'm gonna bang that some day but then
again vampires and lore are usually
hundreds of years old and have most
likely watched their future loved ones
grow up so I don't know if anything in
this setup is really that new no no I
just my hard to believe that Stephenie
Meyer as batshit crazy as a writer she
is will be able to work in a pet
file wolf it just doesn't seem likely
whatever the reasoning is and whatever
imprinting is I'm sure it's stupid and
probably not the main reason to hate the
movies but then we got the queen of
mouth-breathing herself Bella Bella is
where many have the most ethical
problems and they should she's awful
she never fights for herself is overly
dependent is constantly throwing herself
into peril just so her Playgirl
calendars can save her even at her
goddamn wedding she barely cracks a
smile look at that oh I'm getting
married sucks so why does Bella come
across so awful and more importantly why
do so many younger girls want to follow
her because in reality Bella is and has
always been one thing a blank slate mire
whether she realizes it or not is
tapping into a lot of girls and even
women's fantasies which is to have all
their troubles taken away by a handsome
male and yet still be troubled so that
the male can continue to look after her
that's why she's so dependent and that's
why she never does anything because
she's just a skin for female readers to
put on and enter into a fantasy world of
love and excitement that's why
superheroes for a long time we're so
bland and boring if they had distinct
personalities that were different from
your own
you couldn't fantasize about being them
now many would argue that times have
changed and characters in pop culture
have evolved to distinct personas and
identities even in genres that were
considered less important several years
earlier and that's probably the biggest
reason people hate Twilight because a
character nowadays being too much of a
blank slate not doing anything now
equals uncaring selfish lazy too
dependent on everyone and avoiding
responsibility when trouble is afoot
and seeing how the biggest audience for
this series is girls and younger women
many would say this is the worst role
model that could ever be devised for an
evolving world and on the one hand yeah
that sounds exactly right she is the
worst role model for anyone just a
miserable uninteresting little
pain-in-the-ass burden which the story
is building up as the everyday hero
lick it but here's my thought on the
character destroying the fabric of
strength and morality think of all the
things you grew up with whether it be
superheroes fantasy comedy romance most
of these things were not the best
influences either many of them relied on
violence or resolutions I couldn't
really happen in real life
Saved by the Bell for example it's about
a high school boy who constantly causes
trouble and yet still comes out cool and
on top and let's face it at some point
when we were growing up we want to be
like Zack Morris but when we got to high
school it wasn't everything the show
promised was it but it's okay you know
why we adapted we all want to be violent
superheroes or glamorous movie stars but
we quickly discovered that reality had
different plans and we woke up pretty
quick to it why one we're adaptable we
learn and discover that our environment
changes and thus we have to make some
changes to two we grow the fuck up
it's called being smart and young people
do it more often than you think not all
the time but remember when The Simpsons
was said to be destroying the fabric of
America remember how Andrew Dice Clay
was the most shocking person in media
remember how everybody thought Madonna
was gonna be the downfall of society a
lot of things we thought were going to
kill us we actually just evolved beyond
and now we look back and laugh at half
the stuff we were afraid of the early
Simpsons aren't shocking hell of
anything that just kind of awkward
nobody talks about Andrew Dice fucking
clay anymore in effect where the hell he
even is that guy and Madonna
well okay she still has to keep her
clothes on but for different reasons
my guesses will look back on Twilight as
the same way it was stupid
even enjoyably stupid and at times it
probably did go too far watch this old V
log if you want more specifics on that
but for every moron who's actually going
to stay in the mindset that Twilight
represents what life really is dozens of
others are evolving and moving on so is
Twilight the worst thing ever well the
fact is it's not why light that we hate
so much
it's everybody's reaction
it the fact that society made it a hit
and we wonder what that says about us
it's weird and it's messed up but it's
not the first time we've liked unethical
crap so it only proves that we shouldn't
be paranoid about it either just accept
the fact that chances are people will
look back on it one day and laugh the
same way we laugh at something like
saved by the mill it's stupid and I'll
continue to make fun of it
but in terms of the worst thing ever oh
my friends there is so much more
evolution indie evolution that I think
our society has to show I'm the
Nostalgia Critic guide remember so you
don't have to